-First guest tonight
is a Tony-nominated
and Emmy and Peabody
Award-winning actress
and comedian you know from films
such as "Trainwreck"
and "I Feel Pretty"
and her show
"Inside Amy Schumer."
Please welcome back to the sho
one of our favorites --
Amy Schumer.
How are you, Amy?
-Blessed.
Just blessed as hell,
as you know.
-Always. You look wonderful.
-So funny to say "nominated.
-Oh, you mean the fact that,
in your intro,
we mentioned that
you're nominated.
-Yeah, like, "Amy lost" --
Yeah, like, it's a good wa
to be like,
"The following performer
lost this award,
had a night where she though
she might win an award
but lost it."
-Now, do you think
we should start
in our intros
of guests like you
mentioning who won the award
that night?
-I think it would be nice.
I think it'd be nice. Yeah
-Who did you lose --
-And the person who won it
and deserved it...
-Who did you lose your Tony to
-Oh, my gosh, I hate mysel
that I can't remember.
She's a genius.
She did a lot with Mike Nichols.
-Elaine May?
-Glenda Jackson.
-Oh, Glenda Jackson?
-Oh --
Glenda Jackson.
Elaine May won something els
that I was nominated for.
Basically,
I've just had the floor
completely wiped with myself
at every turn.
-I mean, you could do
a lot worse
than losing awards
to Glenda Jackson
and Elaine May.
It should be noted.
-You're right.
But just the same, I have
continued to harass them
ever since.
-Well, they deserve
a little something.
-Sorry. That's me.
-You got something better
than an award, Amy.
-Yeah.
-Your husband found a carrot
this year.
This is an obsession
of my children.
They love this so much.
So this is the carrot.
-It was a real family-pleaser.
And thank you so much
for sharing it on social media
and letting the world enjo
this carrot right here.
I mean...
This is a real carrot
that your husband, Chris, found.
And it just seems like
that's the Heavens knowing
what family needed
to find this carrot.
-It proves that there is a God
and divine intervention.
I had just tucked our son in
and I came out, and Chris --
You know my husband, Chris
Very deadpan.
-Yes.
-You know, he wasn't like --
Like, he would never be
enthusiastic, like,
"I have to show you this."
So you know Chris.
He's just like,
"Here, I thought
you should see this."
And I'm like...
Like, I couldn't --
I just started, whatever it'
called, Instagram Live'ing it.
I was like, "This is --
This is beyond."
I mean, it was a gift for --
It came right when everyon
needed it, at the holidays
People needed that carrot.
-It was like --
It was right around the time,
agree, we needed stories that --
we needed low-stakes stories
that we could all
get on board with,
and this was --
this was the carrot
that 2020 needed to
sort of put a bow on.
-It brought us all together,
and I'm not afraid
to admit that.
-But it sadly -- I mean,
again, there's only so lon
a carrot can be with us
on this Earth.
-Which is the name
of my children's book
that I'm trying to sell.
Yeah, I hate to tell --
I hate to be the one
to share this news
since I was the one who sort o
brought this carrot
into people's -- into lives.
I have to say that it did --
it did pass away.
-You did a --
You held a service?
-Well, yeah, it brought jo
to so many people,
we wanted to show it
the respect it deserved.
I believe we have footage of it,
so maybe we can all mourn
together.
-Yeah, let's mourn together.
-Can we watch?
So you're going to notice,
it was a rainy day.
And the sky, the sort of cloud
just separated.
[ Bagpipes playing ]
-Bagpipes is such a nice -
-It was Scottish.
It was a Scottish carrot.
And several --
It was a team
of at least 12 people.
And there it is.
And it has been laid to rest
And...
But we did bronze it,
and we made like 12 replicas
that we're going to auction of
to charity.
-It's so nice of you to do that.
You know, obviously,
your husband,
as we've also talked about
an incredible chef.
Fresh produce is obviously
a part of your life.
Only somebody
who digs up their own carrot
could find something like that
Have you been healthy?
Do you feel like you've been
healthy through the pandemic
-I, like I think many people
have had many moments
and many reincarnations
during this pandemic.
I have gained and lost
a full person, I would say
You know, we start,
we were really healthy,
and we were stretching
and okay,
and then I gained --
We both got very, very fat
during the pandemic,
which I only really realized
through pictures,
like, when I start being like,
"Oh, whoa. Okay.
Okay, Amy."
But the thing -- Usually,
you have, like, a pair of jean
that --
You know, I don't weigh myself
because I --
I don't, like, believe in that
for me.
But the -- Oh, my gosh,
the TV is on.
I'm just realizing.
Can you see the reflection
We just -- Gene really jus
started watching "Frozen."
Hold on, I'm turning it off.
Don't look at my sweat pants
Okay. Don't --
Don't look at my couch.
So anyway,
what am I talking about?
Oh, so anyway,
we gained so much weight.
But, you know, everybody has
that pair of jeans, usually,
that keeps you honest, right
Like, if you gain weight -
But I don't even know where --
Do you know where
that pair of jeans is?
I don't know where it is.
I don't.
And now I want to cut to a cli
of the funeral I had
for my jeans.
No, I'm just kidding.
Bagpipes, jeans.
-We're very lucky, you and I
food security we have.
But food insecurity is a hug
issue through this pandemic.
And you're actually --
you're helping with that.
-Yeah, I'm embarrassed to sa
I really didn't know that --
that food insecurity
was so prevalent.
But a lot of people
are finding themselves
in lines at food pantries they
never thought they would be.
So I'm very proud to be
partnering with Hellmann's
and they've done so much to tr
to get rid of wasting food
Because I found out from the
that 40% of all food in the U.S.
is wasted, it's thrown away.
And 43% of all of our food i
our own homes is thrown away
And they can help you with som
tips on that at hellmanns.com.
-I want to --
You also did a Hellmann's
Super Bowl commercial.
I want to talk to you
about that.
We'll be right back with mor
from Amy Schumer.